each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hello everybody it's my great pleasure
to introduce David Mona from Berkeley
and we talk about security and privacy
in the RFID so right thank you very much
my name is David molnar and I'm going to
talk to you today about some work I've
done with Andrea sapera from British
Telecom and my advisor David Wagner so
first of all just to set the stage what
is an RFID the term refers to radio
frequency identification and usually
when we talk about RFID we think of a
little tiny chip called a tag that has
an antenna and very often it's pass if
it doesn't have a power supply of its
own but it gets power from the reader
and so we think of tagging one tag for
every item one tag for every palate one
tag for every person so RFID
applications well they're everywhere
just to show you some things up here we
have transit cards this is in London
where people are using contactless smart
cards to pay for their trips every day
this is in library books where over 200
libraries in North America alone are
using a tag on every single book to keep
track of inventory and do automatics
check in and check out the top is fast
track which you may be familiar with
it's an automatic toll payment system
and then on the top right we have chase
banking cards where now you don't even
have to swipe a magnetic strip you just
wave your card and it debits your
account for you we have Prius key fobs
which unlock your car from three feet
away while the key fob is inside your
luggage true story we have electronic
passports on the top right hand top left
hand side we have student IDs that were
actually rolled out in an elementary
school just northwest of Sacramento and
the little tiny white box you can't
really see on the doorway is a little
reader that keeps track of when people
enter and leave yes
yes actually my friend Anna Lee nowit's
had an RFID implanted in her arm as part
of a demonstration of a cloning attack
which I'll talk about in a bit and
actually at the Baja beach club in
Barcelona certain patrons had art by D's
implanted to act as payment devices it
turns out that if you are a young woman
and you're going out on the town you're
not wearing enough to have pockets and
uh so jewelry is okay but you can't pay
for a drink of your jewelry at least not
more than once so they had a VIP they
had a VIP program where they implanted
chip in your hand and you wave your chip
across the bar oh yes of course you
could wear a bracelet but they didn't
you have to remember to put it on so one
of the things I want to get across
before we get into the discussion and I
think this will help clarify the issue
so people say about our if I can do this
RFID can't do that one of the problems
in this space is that the term RFID
refers to a whole range of technologies
and they have very different properties
in terms of how far they can be read how
much computation is possible and
basically what kind of crypto and
security things we have to work with so
this is a little graph it's trying to
get across some ID of the range so on
the top left hand corner we have devices
which are intended to be read from about
10 centimeters away and happily happen
to have a lot of computation so the
device is used in electronic passport
for instance can support digital
signatures they can support encryption
whether or not that gets used is a
completely different question but they
kind of the they can support it and
transit cards for instance use
encryption and mutual authentication to
prevent other people from you know
impersonating the Transit Authority in
the middle case we have the car keys
library books where you can read them
from about them half a meter to a meter
away but they don't have a strong
encryption maybe they can support a
stream cipher or something
homebrewed but they can't support a
standard encryption algorithm yes that
has a lot to do with it yes good this
abortion is dead he gave me my black
edition your speaker / muted car no
problem I don't know I don't know there
are a couple of startups are looking at
things like that there's one that's
trying to use some group key agreement
stuff like the braid group stuff those
people are working on rfid-based crypto
for that kind of class and on the far
right-hand side we have things like what
Walmart is used for its palette kit and
supply chain tracking and what was using
these student IDs we're all it does is
kind of like a digital license plate it
returns a number and that's about it and
has very little computation available
for any kind of cryptography so I
mentioned intended read range and so the
intended read range is differ but the
thing to keep in mind is the adver so
you can always build a better reader and
there's also several different ranges
that people will need to think about so
one is the direct read range so this is
important because a lot of these devices
get their power from the reader and
because of that in or the power to
device you often need to be quite close
so in the case of the passports for
instance because they support so much
computation you need to be about 10
seniors close to power them reliably on
the other hand if it's already intervals
yes exactly it's demonstrated be quite
extendable but on the other hand if
you're eavesdropping if it devices
already powered then in the passport
case and other cases it turns you can be
much farther away and we're starting to
see some data points available so for
instance the electronic product code the
Walmart tags there was a demonstration
in 2005 of reading them at 63 feet away
directly reading them and then in epass
ports there's been eavesdropping at
least four meters possibly more than
reading at over 25 centimeters so
there's been a lot of work here and the
key point to take away is read range is
not a security measure here just because
someone says oh it's a short read range
that doesn't make it a secure device and
in fact even a short read range is
enough to cause trouble so let me share
with you a little personal
story all right I was involved in some
art public policy regarding RFID in
California as part of it I got the had
the pleasure of working with some
wonderful lobbyists from the RFID
industry who continually said that you
know it's a short read range it's no
problem it's no problem it turns out
that the swipe cards used in the capital
are vulnerable to a kind of cloning
attack if I can get close to you and
read your card I can make a copy of it
so I personally took a little reader
into the Capitol in last August and got
about nine people just by bumping into
them so avi Rubin who's a security
consultant has a very nice quote about
this he like to say it's like
pickpocketing except you don't actually
have to touch the person and it's the
same thing that happens here and less
turn privacy protections are put in
place transmitted farther later on yes
so be close by and then yes and there's
at least there's at least two groups one
in Cambridge University in the UK and
one in Tel Aviv University who are
trying to do that experimentally right
now and that's a seat so the question
was can you eavesdropping and relay the
signal further away and the answer is
yes in principle and there are some
people working on that so one thing that
you know we talked about the read range
thing you should ask next it's okay
what's on these tags well why do I care
if someone's reading my tag Jenna
there's a minimum of a unique identifier
so you can think of this some kind of
license plate and the actual identifier
changes so library books have a barcode
walmart has this electronic product code
which is like the universal product code
you see with today's barcodes but it
goes to in a unique item instance it's
not just this is a can of beans it's
this is this fifth can of beans that was
shipped to walmart from this place at
this time and building access cards like
the ones many people use at least have a
unique ID number to tell you apart from
your friend who shouldn't be in that
door but it turns out is that many
applications have more so electronic
passports because they have to work
anywhere in the world have your
photograph your full name and your birth
date among other things and credit card
number credit
cards have turns out that they have your
full name and your credit card number so
why is this important well skimming is
an issue right because RFIDs don't tell
you when they're being read there's an
issue about can someone read it without
my knowledge and this is a particular
concern the tag is carrying something
like my photograph which will then be
used as a part of comparing me against
the document or as was shown recently by
researchers from University of
Massachusetts Amherst credit cards so
these people wonderful people from
University of Massachusetts and RSA took
a look at 20 of the most recent RFID
credit cards from different issuers
including American Express MasterCard
and Visa these companies acclaimed that
there's no privacy problem because all
your data would be stored encrypted
there's no problem you shouldn't worry
about it please use these cards and
spend more money well it turns out
that's not true it turns out in all 20
of these cases all of these cards sent
the full name and the credit card number
and they were able to take the credit
card numbers sniff from one of these
cards and then order stuff over the
internet with it yes today yet now yet
to use public key crypto so II for the
same cryptos I mean nineteen nineteen
sixties technology encryption have they
changed here ah well in my experience
trying to decipher what credit card
companies mean when they say we use
128-bit encryption is a lost cause there
are standards that you're that
mastercard because have worked on that
would use public key crypto but to my
knowledge they have not been deployed in
the United States I don't know about
Europe there's something plain text yes
the same plain text then how can the UN
claim that it's secure let me play for
the hell they are PR people they can
claim anything they want I mean this
it's based on proximity yes it's if you
push them so before this report came out
they said oh it's all encrypted
therefore there's no problem after the
report came out they said Oh
ninety-eight percent of the cards are
encrypted you just got the ones that
weren't oh and by the way you know you
aren't liable for any problems that
happen if your card is stolen which may
be true is true but
duh it would be nice to say that before
hand instead of lying about what
encryption was used so what you have it
on the right there is Senator Charles
Schumer from New York and he went on to
the street manhattan two days ago
holding up rfid credit cards to tell
people about this issue and is now
calling for us or truth in labeling when
it comes to security and rfid credit
cards so this has actually been the news
recently and all because you know yes
yes as a matter of fact I did I'm glad
you asked that question because we're
going to see a screenshot soon so skinny
just people before that I just want to
mention so skimming gets in this issue
about cloning so if you have an rfid
device and all it does is send a unique
identity identifying number and that's
all it does it becomes quite easy to
make a clone that is a device that looks
to the reader just like the rfid card
and this has been demonstrated over and
over again so the very chip is a human
implantable RFID you put it in your arm
and then you can scan your arm to prove
that you're you at least that's the
sales pitch it turns out is quite easy
to clone this and make a device that
replays the same number so a friend of
mine her name's Anna Lee she had one
implanted by the company and then she
got this other fellow Johnson West used
to come on up and scan her arm and then
make a clone of her Barry chip it's been
done for car key fobs and there there
was cryptography used but turned out to
be weak it turned out to be something
that was a stream cipher could be fairly
easily reverse engineered and turn I
have a 40-bit key oops but the more the
more interesting things from my point of
view recently is building access cards
not every building access card has its
property but many of them do and in fact
the cards that we use UC Berkeley the
student ID cards have this property all
they are is a simple unique identifier
and all it happens when you get into a
door is the door reader looks at it and
says oh you're the you're on my approved
list I'll let you in these are trivial
to clone it's been done at least twice
so Jonathan West used in 2003 and
i T radio society did it in 2004 and
I've done it um I'm not going to hmm
before after these guys it was part of a
demonstration in California and I'm not
going to try it on your Microsoft ID
cards because I want to not get thrown
in jail so but the thing about this
cloning risk is it violates an
assumption a lot of people have an RFID
is unique so if you talk to people in
the pharmaceutical industry some of them
have this amazing idea that just because
it's a chip it's impossible to clone
certain lobbyists have this
understanding as well and the problem
with the cloning issue is that because
they're being used to authenticate
high-value items like people or
pharmaceuticals even a short read range
as a problem because all you have to do
is get close to the item once and then
you can clone it so all I have to do is
it close to you once and then I can come
in as you after hours and this is a
concern because people design their
systems assuming this is unique yes
ception that I have to get close to it
in the first place I many of the systems
I'd seen seem to be the case but you
could guess a valid or if I being Ted
that's correct you don't have you just
have to be able to clone something
that's correct or you know just keep
trying different ID numbers they're
quite short usually yes if I remember
the inverse square law right and the
regrade you been to the power of
transmitter yes basically if I went get
you some distance 5-megawatt get you a
slightly bigger distance yes that's
correct and people have actually started
doing some of that work like the work
from the people at Tel Aviv have
simulated how far out that curve goes
and then they've started actually
building things along those lines
doesn't go as far as a moon yeah not not
that they've done so far excremental e
the longest range i know for building
access cards is about two feet mit guys
claim about two feet which is enough to
have a doorway that records and clones
everyone walking through it so the thing
is if you happen to be a cryptographer
you'll probably be thinking right now
gee you know there are ways around this
or ways to fix this problem but
unfortunately they're not being deployed
or if they're being deployed as in the
our key fobs are using insufficient
cryptography but one thing that happens
even if you use cryptography is often
there's a unique identifier / RFID that
anyone can pick up and so this leads to
a tracking issue anyone can track and so
we had a question the audience about a
recent work done at University of
Washington where these nike plus ipod
kits I don't know people have seen them
there they consist of a little sensor
goes in your shoe and it talks to your
iPod and it tells you how many steps
you've taken so you can use it to plot
your workout unfortunately it won't talk
only to your iPod it'll talk to my ipod
and his and his and his and what it
gives you is a unique identifier so you
can think of it like a license plate it
follows your shoe everywhere the shoe
goes and what these people did was they
built a little system that would
actually track these identifiers around
town so this is an actual screenshot
from their work and I'm sorry it uses
Google instead of Microsoft but it's all
right and you can get the paper and some
more information from there a variant of
this which is actually more concerned
than me is something I like to call hot
listing so in the tracking you have a
bunch of unique identifiers and maybe
later on you figure out who they are
maybe you don't but in hot listing you
only care about a few specific people or
a few specific items and let me give you
a real world example in 2003 the FBI put
out a warning to its agents saying we
want people of almanacs because people
of all max might be terrorists looking
to blow up specific locations in United
States I'm not making this up you can't
make this stuff up so for a while the
FBI onenote angle of an almanac that's
hot lists that they had now a
hypothetical hot list if I step an RFID
reader at a gun show where political
rally I can get a list of all the IV's
that were at that gun show or political
rally these are all legal but it's also
quite interesting to know who's there
later on I can compare an RFID against
the list and say oh was that person at
the gun show
I'd I have know her name but now I know
where they were I know that they're on
my list of people I'm interested in now
there was a slightly more out there a
version of this attack that actually
showed up on primetime TV recently Bob
Saget wasn't a sort of law and order
special victims unit so that's the
actress that was playing his wife and he
thought that she was cheating on him so
in the wall order episode he implants
roof an rfid and then he keeps track of
readers around you know his friends
homes and then he doesn't care about any
other ID he only cares about if she is
going into his friends place and it all
ends in tears but you can watch the
video for that you want to just a cell
phone and because IQs it's a try using
several technology or all the devices so
it turns out it might be illegal to
track people by cell phone if there is a
wiretap statute that may or may not be
interpreted in such a way to say
civilians tracking others by cell phone
is legal I've asked the same question
I've thought about building such a
device myself but there are no rules of
RFID there there's just no rules yet
perhaps that's the case we many do we
need more rules or perhaps the case we
need to fix of technology that's a
different question now one thing it also
comes up is you know is it do all the
problems go away because it's only a
number and the answer is no so first of
all cloning is still a problem if I can
guess your student your student or
employee ID I can often clone a tag if
there's no other problems tracking is
still a problem and hot listing is still
a problem and I think and I hope that
can convince you these are still issues
that we have to worry about or at least
be aware of before we implement rfid
systems because of as we just heard from
this question answer there's no rules
about who can or can't eavesdrop on
these things in California it's legal
for me to skim your RFID without telling
you as far as I can tell it's legal for
me to make a clone of your RFID as long
as I don't use the break
into a building so the other thing that
comes up is these databases exists
somewhere that map IDs the names or IDs
to other information otherwise there
would be no point to this technology who
says that database won't be sold to
someone who says that I won't create a
parallel database of my own and then
sell it to you so here's a real world
example license plates you go to reverse
license plate look up and you type that
into your favorite search engine or you
know you take a look at any of these
private detective sites they will sell
you the name and address of a license
plate you give them for a very minimal
amount of money some of them make you
fill out a form that gives a good reason
and others don't yes different from the
dip people carrying a credit card right
my information is in your car to
accommodate abyss I anyway I need to
trap them somehow well it serves you
with the credit card what you're giving
up is your purchase information which is
sensitive but here the question is about
your location information where did you
go who did you talk to that kind of
thing and the other issue is notice
right so if the credit card you know
that information is being collected you
have the opportunity to review it at the
end of every billing period here I can
sniff your RFID and you'll never know
you'll never have an opportunity to
figure out what's going on there don't
want people to know you where you are
you might decide to pay cash exact it
but you don't have that opportunity if
you can make no I mean our friend you
must have a off part no it doesn't
there's no off button though should add
codes or buttons or no in it you can
build RFID with an off button and people
have done it in the lab but that is not
what happens so for instance a
fast-tracked electronics whole
collections there's no off button in
California their issue of a mylar bag
because people talked about privacy now
the problem is the way the fast track
works is you attach it to your
windshield so in order to get privacy
protection from mylar bag you have to
take it off the windshield put in the
bag and put your glove compartment every
time you move
people don't do that now what we've seen
happen however is those databases have
actually been subpoenaed for use in
divorce trials that is the divorce
lawyer wants to know that oh you were
with your mistress on such and such date
and she lives in such and such place I
will subpoena the records from your toll
plaza and I will be able to establish
you at least we're in this part of the
state at this time our for instance
policemen have used this kind of
information in criminal investigations
these databases are being used today and
the question is will we have noticed and
choice about and what we have control
over that data yes but more generally is
the stocking up on these RFID visit hope
all this detail can you is there come
down occasion to hell you could I'm not
aware of any that have executable code
at this point the ones that have more
than just a unique identifier in the
electronic passport it was because it
had to work anywhere in the world even
if the reader is offline in the credit
card company they were working from
legacy systems that require your name
and credit card information it that did
answer your questions very application
dependent unfortunately but I still
think that even if it's just a unique
identifier it's still an issue
especially if you don't have a good way
of turning it off so the question is you
can't we do better and part of my talk
will be to talk you about two ways in
which we can do better on notice and
choice and control over the data but let
me just briefly talk about some existing
techniques this is not an exhaustive
list there's a lot of work out here this
is just some very widely known things I
want to talk about and before moving on
to some new ideas so one thing that's
happened in the retail space is a kill
command you tell the tag to die and then
it never talks to you again so this is
actually in the Walmart type tags this
was implemented as part of a response to
consumer privacy concerns and it's great
if you never need to tag again it's not
so good for library books for student
IDs for employee IDs or anything else
where you need to use the tag on
continual basis
walking through the aisles of Walmart
kill not yet not yet but a better
question is anyone ever seen at a store
that actually kills tags on checkout and
the answer to that is not yet either
does a killer go mad if any opens
advantage again diagonal cutters hahaha
diagonal give me like physically cutting
physically cutting with driven to so no
there's nothing against that and
actually IBM has us has this thing they
call the clipped tag where they actually
have a preparation so you can tear the
tag in half so the reason for that is if
it's just a software kill you can't tell
by looking at if it's dead or not and so
the second second thing has come up and
I've already alluded this earlier with
the mylar bag is a shield device so for
instance then we're about to issue the
United States is about to issue a border
crossing card between the United States
and Canada unlike the e-passport it only
contains a unique identifier but also
unlike the e passport will be readable
from 20 feet away so the Department of
Homeland Security Department of State
say it's not a problem because we'll
give everyone a Luminum foil shield that
they can use to shield it when not in
use and this is a problem because it
puts the burden of protecting privacy on
the user it also turns out that people
lose these shield devices or they'd
never get them in the first place or
just using this brain coming in sorry so
this is it possible to but I always put
my credit cards in my wallet in my back
pocket like probably ninety five percent
of men yes so you can credit card so is
there a way that I can have something
you know in my wallet that is
interfering or somehow it doesn't have
to be a shield it could be some
interference or a little bit of foot yes
so aluminum foil feel got to be it has
to enclose the entire card so if there's
even a little bit left out and the
signal can get well this is one of those
black art type of things so i can tell
you my entirely unscientific experience
with a potato chip bag and a prius key
fob I found it has completely wrap
around the key fob in order to work
bill you know special pocket to be
searched yes and people are already
building wallets special mylar line
wallets yes which frequency band of
those tag working it depends on the
application for the northern border card
915 megahertz for credit cards fifteen
point five six megahertz sorry 13.56
megahertz purchase license before users
know they're unlicensed the 13.56 is the
international scientific and medical
band and there's no license needed for
the 915 it actually differs between
Europe Japan and America but they're all
unlicensed sorry your question or I was
curious about like
kind of alluded that one problem two is
like the attack not known yeah that's
true so I guess we
better labeling and better notice and
pressure on manufacturers to tell you if
something has an RFID in it that's what
would it take on the weaker devices to
have at least the counter of how many
times is being read so if you're really
careful you know there's a funny reading
that shouldn't happen so my
understanding i'm talking to people who
work at a certain line 50 megahertz
manufacturers actually the counter is
harder than crypto and that's because
changing state requires more power so it
actually looks better to have a
stateless device it has like a stream
cipher than to have some of the counter
and this came up because I want to do
like prg with a counter and you know for
a while discussing the second yes is
read-only some of them are some of them
aren't the Pat the northern border card
is read-only the e passport is currently
read only the credit card is read-only
but they don't have to be for instance
the oyster card in London keeps track of
where you've been during that day and
the reason they do that is because they
have fair rules that say if you've done
certain number of transfers and you
don't get charged so much I'm sorry to
be so out there but the answer really is
it depends so I'm going to talk about
two new pieces of work that I and my
collaborators have done so the first one
is I want to talk about the idea that
every time the RFID is read it gives you
a different identity so we call it a
pseudonym it's a new ID every time so
instead of be on the track someone by
their license plate think of as their
license plate changes every two seconds
if you know a special secret you can
tell who it is but if you don't if
you're just someone eavesdropping then
you can't now one and i'll talk about a
way of doing this sort of a straw man
and i'll show that fails or it becomes
inefficient when we have many RFIDs and
this is a problem because real instances
have had as many as a million RFID tags
the university Nevada Las Vegas library
for instance has tagged on a million
books and then I'll talk about an
extension where I can give you limited
time access to my RFID I can give you
some delegation and then we'll switch
gears and we'll talk about the reader
side will say okay we've been talking
about the tags now let's talk about how
do we know these readers are doing what
they're supposed to be doing
and I'll talk very briefly about using
trusted computing to enhance RFID
privacy so here's the first technique
pseudonyms we have Alice we have the
Cheshire Cat we have a book alice is the
owner of the book the Cheshire Cat is
listening in and Alice sees a particular
ID from the book the first time it's red
and so Alice happens to know that that
ID probably means that it's lame is
Aurra by Victor Hugo she reads it again
and she gets another ID and she's oh ok
it's still lateness but the cheshire cat
doesn't have any information about the
book he's never read Victor Hugo before
or something so he sees these two
different IDs and he doesn't even know
they're from the same book so we have
the tag on the book is giving a
different ID each time alice is
authorized to know what the book is so
she can tell their same but the Cheshire
Cat can't so here's a first try and I'm
going to need a little piece of
cryptography called a pseudo-random
function and what this is is it's a
function takes two arguments a key and
an input and the idea is that if you
don't know the key then it looks like a
random function you won't be able to
predict the outputs you won't be able to
figure distinguish it from a random
function will give every single tag a
different key and Alice knows all the
keys so if there's a million books
there's a million keys one for each book
and Alice knows all of them so the first
try is the tag and pick some random
input and it can send the P its consent
this pseudo random function of that
input keyed with its special key and an
Alice can tell for any given one of
these pseudonyms whether or not it
matches a particular book she just says
oh I am going to check that is this book
5 i'll look up the key for book five and
i'll see if that that function evaluated
on this particular random value gives me
the correct answer people following so
far basically because the talus and the
tag share a secret the tag can keep
sending random looking values and Alice
can figure out which tag it is
but there's a little bit of a problem
here which tat which key should you use
the whole point is Alice doesn't know
which book it is so she doesn't know
which key to use so the obvious we can
do is try each key in turn this will
take a while if there's a million or
more even if you a very fast machine Eve
you may want to identify tens or
hundreds of tags going by yes number of
the low side I think you let both half a
billion tags for their separation they
did they did but any individual reader
might only see no hundreds at one time
but yes Gillette for not just using
public key performance yes performance
we want to use something has only a
symmetric key cryptography because of
performance and power issues that you
had a question so this is a pravachol
you can think of as private
authentication how do you and I
determine we share a secret without
actually revealing a secret to the
adversary so here's the solution we came
up with it's a tree of secrets if some
of you have seen multicast encryption
you may have seen something very much
like this it's very conceptually simple
think of each of the leaves there is a
different tag and we build a full binary
tree each node is a different secret the
tag knows the secrets from the root to
the leaf Alice knows all the secrets and
what we're going to do is going to use
this tree structure to allow us to walk
down the tree to find the individual tag
and so here's how we generate a
pseudonym we start off each of the keys
from the tree is going to key a
different pseudo-random function so then
we pick a random numbers and input each
of these functions we string them
together and we output the result Alice
hmm when she gets a pseudonym she
doesn't know which leaf it is but she
can tell is it the left secret of the
right secret the root and then once
she's checked that she just walks down
the tree of those okays a left secret or
right secret of next level and she can
stew that she can walk down the tree
just by checking these p RF values
until she gets to the particular
identity of the tag and of course it
does nothing says it has to be a binary
tree you can change the branching factor
and optimize and do whatever you want so
yes right actually out yes you can
replay I'll get to this in a second but
the thing is you can replay old
pseudonyms but you can't create new ones
and the reason is that because it's a
pseudo-random function you won't be able
to predict the output of the function in
the future and i'll talk about why
that's an interesting trade-off in a bit
or why i think it's a septa bowl
trade-off in a bit but before we get
there I want to mention that this second
piece of the puzzle is delegation I want
to give you some of the secrets but not
all of them I want to give you some
ability to read my tag but not all the
time and there's two reasons one is
maybe I'm let you borrow my book I want
you to be able to read the book rfid for
a while but then you might give it back
to me so if you're a library for
instance but the second thing is if i
have a reader out there in the field or
in a store stores get broken into and
people make off with things so i want to
limit my exposure if something is broken
into or compromised so the way we do
that is every single tag will have its
own delegation tree every tag will have
a counter so this does require a counter
this requires more than the previous
approach and every time the tag is read
the counter increments and it yields a
different path in the tree and we do
this we actually use a ggm construction
very simple thing that's already been
used many times before but the main idea
is what's easy to derive a children
given a parent and it's hard to derive a
parent given the children so this is
sort of a system level view you have
Allison one hand she gives two different
parts of her tree to the two different
readers and in the RFID tag outputs a
different path each time it's red so
after a while reader A's tree will just
expire so you can see in the right hand
side reader a is for the left-hand part
of the tree and the reader be is a right
hand subtree yes after a time
no keeping drug of time is even harder
than keeping your counter I should I
misspoke i made after a number of reads
so over time tightly read many times and
eventually reader a is tree will expire
because you'll simply here it's four
times and then the tree it will no
longer be producing pseudonyms that it
understands so the benefits of this
approach that I've talked about is
because the IDS it generates look just
like a standard RFID you don't change
installed readers that is if you have a
fast track reader that's used to seeing
a 32-bit identity from a car you can use
this to upgrade to something that
preserves privacy well the same time not
having to go all over the highways and
change every single reader it foils
tracking in hot listing because you have
a different identity every time you
won't be able to correlate to signs of
the same tag and as we heard earlier you
can replay old pseudonyms so it doesn't
get around cloning entirely but it means
that you can't ever create new
pseudonyms so if you have a back-end
that looks at all the students you've
seen and looks for commonalities and you
can mitigate that yes resource question
how hard is it to get good pseudo-random
number generators
so in round number generators happy hard
it turns out that it several
technologies have hardware generators
like unbalanced diodes and things that
you can deal with those are both
difficult it turns out that is an ideal
world I went and talked to one of these
RFID manufacturers in ideal world they'd
like to see a completely deterministic
stateless protocol I had to tell them
that that's a little difficult to do and
still getting some kind of security to
which we become accustomed but hardware
random number generators turn out to be
somewhat more feasible yes compared to
maintain stake at these long range
distances for instance the new
electronic product code the generation
to actually requires a pseudo-random
generator because their collision
avoidance protocol is randomized
probably not okay brides Eric where I
don't pseudo-random for random
understand so that's true it is a fizzle
and biggest in one toll is actually a
linear feedback shift register but it's
not great unfortunately but but I'm told
that that's actually better they think
it's better than having to keep state
and the other of course nice thing is a
scales logarithmic another tax yes
you're the probabilistic Corinthian to
this was the formula
with this skin for generating two names
instead of current EU again what the
what's the currency I go what's the
guarantee the guarantee oh you can
guarantee that if it's a valid tag it
will always be identified there's a
small possibility identify other tags as
well due to collisions but it's very
small it's negligible and then if it's
not the valid if it's not the correct
tag then assuming there's your not being
attacked by it with a replay attack then
the chance that you get a collision in
all of the different places is small and
you can you can calculate this but the
downsides well for one thing if you
delegate your readers that it turns out
that the overhead of the reader after
delegation is linear in the number of
total tags delegated we think this is
usually going to be small but still an
issue because they don't have the full
tree they only have these spud sub trees
and the big problem with this approach
is tag cherkis this isn't an issue for
impersonation and cloning because every
tag is at least one key that no other
tag does but an issue for privacy
because if I have tagged a and tag be
and they share some keys and I break in
to tag a I can now tell it tag be shared
some of those keys so this tree
structure actually has an interesting
trade-off between privacy and detect
compromise and efficiency and there's
been at least two works that looked at
trying to quantify how much privacy that
is trying to figure out what does it
mean to quantify privacy there's been a
work that was done this past summer on
how best to structure trees to limit
this loss and then dangan ostagar talked
about is there a lower bound and how
well we can do they got some very basic
results but it's still a pretty open
problem as to how far you can go with
this approach and then there's an
alternative approach via pre-computation
that works reasonably well but only if
you plan to read about each tag at most
16 times so that's the pseudonyms that
I've talked about that's our idea and
then what sort of switch gears again
let's talk about the reader
so I talked about making the tag is
responsible for privacy and saying okay
the tag gives a different ID each time
you can't track the tag you can't link
to sightings together now I'm going to
turn around and say okay we have these
readers so marks and spencer is going to
be putting up readers in its stores and
it's going to promise you that they will
only read Marks & Spencer rfid tags how
do you know our answer is you're going
to leverage some features of trusted
computing so just to recap in trusted
computing the situation is we have a
small trusted platform module it's
installed on your motherboard you can't
break into it but you can control the
entire rest of the computer and we are
going to need two features in particular
ones remote attestation where you can
tell people what software you're running
and the other is sealed storage where
you can tell the trusted platform module
I want you to lock this blob of
information only decrypt it for the
particular software that I tell you to
they shouldn't not bother with public
key no never station is hideously
inefficient this is for the reader where
we don't care about efficiency so we can
do everything we do privacy CA we can do
Lucy on schoo stuff no because what's
happening is the percolators between the
reader and an auditor me and you and my
handheld that's fine for my food Spencer
or whoever but if I'm just a robe with a
cutter out there this does not handle
road readers this only deals with policy
compliance for nice people and then you
have to do other things like listen for
bad emanations from rogue readers and
fine and destroy them hmm it's not a
complete solution yes try that at the US
Embassy in Moscow ha don't they already
have people doing that listening for
rogue emanations only does it all the
time yes order to make a wet level yes
probably true so this is a very limited
solution but I still think it's an
interesting for the key because we will
see legitimate enterprises deploying
these readers all over the place and we
want to know what kind of data are
keeping about us
so this is a basic idea that we had we
published a position paper sort of
saying this is how it might look like my
colleagues of British Telecom have now
gone actual implementation and it kind
of works so the basic idea is you have
sort of two services you have a policy
agent policy engine and a consumer agent
the policy engine encodes things like I
only read Marks and Spencers tags or I
only read tagging all in the tuesdays or
I only read tags and have a certain
privacy bit set to OFF and the consumer
agent is just a logging engine the
policy engine also keeps track of any
shared secrets so we can support cases
where the tariff ID tag needs some
secrets like in the pseudonym protocol
we talked about and then there's a
reader core that just basically
interfaces between those two and the TPM
and you can think of as including the
Linux kernel and so on you could or the
windows kernel yes goodness Colonel
thank you but the basic idea is
something that we've already heard the
ver you think of a privacy auditor and
it could be you could be me it could be
a third-party like the Electronic
Frontier Foundation anyone in the world
who wants a check this box is actually
doing what the sign says it's doing
walks up to it and asks the box to
perform remote attestation and then the
box will say oh look I'm running this
consumer agent this consumer agent will
give you this log you know I'm running
the correct software so even if you're
not allowed to see what my policy is
Mike and consumer agent that you picked
out will tell you it meets your criteria
so it's doing more devastation of Basin
software
you're no way of knowing if it doesn't
have a second set of modules the batsman
todor fib chips that's what the sealed
storage is for so the idea is that you
then take all the inputs from the RFID
and you seal them so they can only be
open by that set of software thinking of
the attack where I have one box which is
two separate things it is TPM is doing
everything it should write and something
else that's rogue and you're saying well
there's a box there it's a big box so i
don't mind emanations from that buff
that's right and that's that's an issue
that you'd have to solve by saying okay
can you make sure the reader core is
only binding to one rfid reader i don't
know how to solve that so but the
benefit you know is we've already talked
about anyone can audit it you can
arbitrarily complete complicated
policies and the sealed storage can keep
track of secrets like what readers I
what things I've seen or what secrets I
need but the downside it doesn't address
rogue readers even rogue readers in the
same box and changing policy after
deployment turns out to be a nasty
problem because you may have had some
assumptions about those policies were
and now you're using sealed storage so
you change any of the software
underlying software then you're in
trouble ah so one thing that I've been
thinking about a little bit though is
you know why is anyone going to use
these technologies right so I've given
you two new privacy enhancing
technologies and will they be used why
or why not and well I don't think this
is a question computer scientists can
answer alone because it has to do with
what actual people implementing RFID
need and want and there are a lot of
broken bodies on this road we are all
familiar with technologies that looked
great and got people very excited but
then never made it to implementation and
regrettably privacy enhancing
technologies have a lot of broken bodies
more than usual so I'm going to sketch
one way of thinking about why you might
want something like this and this is
just a work in progress so I welcome
your feedback on this even if they say
it's full of it so let's think of a
simple killing game
so this game in the economic sense of
game so recall that there's this feature
called the kill command in RFIDs where
you can say at the point of sale I want
this device to be dead kill it and we're
going to say the customer can either buy
an item were not buy an item that has
RFID tag in it the merchant can kill it
or not kill it we'll just assume the
customer benefits from a dead RFID and
the merchant benefits from a live RFID
like he doesn't want the bottom of
killing it or any things that can sell
the information later and we'll make an
assumption final assumption the customer
can't tell if the RFID is actually dead
so this is actually pretty close to
today the merchant doesn't want to spend
the money to buy a killing device I
can't tell the thing is dead so to kill
it its return we want it to be live
again exactly exactly so you want their
good reasons why this might model
reality a little bit so you can build a
payoff matrix as we all you know know
and love from economics and that's a
payoff matrix and perhaps this won't be
surprising by now but the equilibrium
point for this payoff matrix turns out
we don't buy and don't kill it turns out
this is an example of what George
Akerlof got the Nobel Prize for it's a
market for lemons that is there are good
merchants who will kill and their lemon
merchants who won't and the customer
can't tell the difference so you just
sort of look at the possibilities and it
turns out that the Nash equilibrium is
for the all merchants to not kill since
they know I can't tell and for me to not
buy since I know they can't tell that I
and yeah yes it's not very cryptic assoc
ology some merchants have a hundred or
two hundred years worth of reputation go
to
and that baby may change the game
because it wouldn't be brought back to
the merchant yes that's right and in
economics they talk about repeated games
is a way of capturing that kind of
reputation if you think you're going to
play again in the future but I want to
focus on a slightly different economic
issue and that's the issue of signals so
the economist Michael Spence talked
about this notion of a signal to get out
of this problem so the thing is the
original game was in the context of used
cars dealerships now as we all know
people actually do buy cars we used car
dealership so there's got to be
something going on that over and above
the small game I just talked about he
talked about well what if you have a
notion of something that a player can
either buy a signal or not by a signal
but the player is bad or if the players
going to screw you in the second in the
game the signal would cost a great deal
but player is good it doesn't cost very
much at all and he was able to show that
if the costs work out only the good
people will buy the signal and all the
bad people won't and his example was a
college degree so many people know the
fact you have a piece of paper may or
may not mean very much about what you
learned but the fact that you were
willing to spend the effort the time and
know the money to get one is probably a
signal that you have some effort in time
and so the idea is could trusted
computing be an RFID signal because in
order to break the trip in order to send
a bad signal do you have to break the
tamper resistance on the trusted
platform module and my colleague Nikita
borissov right I know some of you may
know you know he always ask me well how
much tamper resistance is enough you
know the TPM may be enough for
protecting a song but is it enough for
protecting a reputation of a 200 year
old company I don't know but it's the
recap these applications are widespread
they're increasing we're about to roll
out a new northern border card uses RFID
we've been rolling out payment cards use
RFID and we have electronic passports
today use RFID and in many of these
cases our security and privacy problems
I've mentioned your cloning tracking and
hot listing and they just keep coming up
and I've talked about two approaches a
pseudonym protocol and the trusted rfid
reader that we might be able to use to
help us with these and this is just
where to learn more certain people's
theses and there's an rfid bibliography
that you guys have juan holds it's a
really amazing resource it has pretty
much every paper that's been published
in the last four or five years on this
topic most of them online links to are
you done running okay and if you're
interested in learning more about this i
would just say pick up the paper you
know see what kind of deployments people
have and then you can get readers for
quite a small amount of money for the
nearest near term stuff to 13.5 six
megahertz stuff and then you just go out
and start reading things and then beyond
rfid is just one slide about why I'm
here and why I'm visiting Patrice I'm
now focusing on finding bugs without
human oversight I'm now more interesting
software security I think our fight is a
great area but I've also think that's
starting reach a little bit of
diminishing returns I want to find more
things and I'm particularly interested
in catching sigh and unsigned conversion
bugs and I have an approach that be
happy to talk to anyone about where I
try to infer type information on
binaries and then use a Sat solver to
try to generate test cases that exhibit
such bugs and I look forward to hearing
more from all of you about what you've
been doing so that's it that's my talk
and if you have any questions let me
know yes your return to the
questionnaire might be proud of you how
much CPU hard you'll need for all the
stuff and how much is available in there
as RFID chip because I heard hundred
Hertz arm and
we won't exhibit I didn't like it ok so
for by soon den protocol you need a
pseudo-random function so think of a EES
think of something like that there's
been a group at University of Graz in
Austria that can get AES implementation
about 3000 gates so that's Martin feld
Hoffer fel dho fer and his students they
they've been really aggressively working
on minimizing the gate counter for AES
and then you could use my protocol um
but in general you basically have to ask
about a specific chip and specific
application know any more questions
great thanks very much